walk into this video playing
International Master Sherlock from
Greece which was opposed to a Sicilian
check let's not get into some hot
theoretical debug the Moscow variation
with we should be five really has gained
lots of popularity and recently and it's
a valid way to to play you know be
Bishop III or be - yeah I don't really
know it well let's try the fianchetto
one problem is that like an almost
always manages to go d5 here and then
it's really not too inspiring
let's try I don't know maybe this one
let's try this move if he goes d5 I take
take Knight f5 where he's playing rather
quickly
yeah well a six is a very typical move
in this type of position
hmm should I play a form hmm not sure
now I can probably use some text tactics
against me with this diagonal I don't
like that cringey three years another
possible news let's do that this was one
idea of queen d3 getting the Queen over
a ball centralized and the screen is
always looking looking against we'll be
looking at g7 hmm what about Knight f5
let's let's have a look at that night at
d5 I mean now d5 8590 f5
hmm yeah it's actually too interesting
not to play it I mean maybe it's a
complete job but let's let's just try
that I think it's an interesting way to
go my blue shirt on B sub B 2 gets very
active now and I'm not quite sure what
he's doing now I can they can try a
knight Age 5 but I have Queen G for
attacking it and yeah and there's also
Knight age 6 hood it's not clear to me
right age 6 King f8 this is this is
probably not great but what about Queen
Queen to g4 how does it protect h5 he
cannot retreat on g6 I have a check and
85 ok let's let's try that this is at
least interesting them simply also I
have 85 in the position opening of the
ephah and asking some questions for for
this knight on c6 and the bishop on e7
he's got the Queen on big ATM this is
very often a course for problems having
the Queen so far off yeah I can give the
check this was one idea or I can just
take on on on d5 yeah let's do that
open up everything 95 is hanging these
seven so it's it's not clear what is
next with this
I'm just threatening eat XD 5 the md5
takes is 6 I mean okay now I can I can
take it should I now probably assured
and now what what's next this is very
interesting yeah all night is 7s one
possibility not a bad one mmm-hmm but
probably not the best move
I'd like to threaten Quint xh5 this
would be great putting something on the
third ring now this is nice why not rook
e8 Queen takes h5 is actually actually a
way to play
Mookie ed quintics age 5g takes Luke g3
Czech Bishop g7 looked x g7 check King
f8 rook takes h7 huh I'm not sure that
it is a winning really it looks it looks
devastating what is it winning
I'm not quite sure what his movers
really besides from p8 some it's there's
some counter-attack you're getting the
Queen involved I don't really know and
there's also the Czech Bishop g7 night
h6 now this might be me
this is maybe even better now is
spending lots of time can you create I
will just take it 3-3
no yeah well I'll do that anyway no
using and spending any more time this
was the idea all along so let's just
grab the thing g3 Bishop g7 is there
something better
I could take on make a tick with the
bishop always not taking it hmm
surprising I know I can just keep the
peace and I will do that I didn't see a
direct win which is probably my own my
own yeah my own problems because there
is one there is a winner pretty sure
about that
there was a win I didn't see it though
now I'm just a piece up and preparing to
retreat the the night it didn't have a
square available where the Queen is
protected yeah I'm not perfectly I know
this is a nice square I wanted to say
I'm not perfectly coordinated but no
it's fine again
that's the nidus excellent only five of
course yeah I just consolidate my
position black resigns and this was was
interviewing but I really I didn't see a
win after the if we take the Queen it's
probably a yeah it is winning but I
didn't I didn't see I have the precise
win the comp cams Bishop g7 is winning
yeah I actually intended to do that and
this is just plus two
yeah yeah yeah or this one yeah this
this is this I saw this is interesting
keeping the King in a net here to to
threaten dismayed
and yeah maybe I would have found this
one I saw the idea to prevent f6 but the
cleaner seems to be Bishop takes g7
interestingly enough because this this
this is the instant mate yeah yeah this
is the problem he needs to play h6 I was
always thinking okay I can go f6 and
what what's the idea but of course he
must play this move and then I have this
with a check
yeah this is this is very very clear-cut
the only move and then I'm taking and he
cannot recapture I mean this is the
problem I had this is very nice yeah
okay then then he really couldn't
couldn't take the knight but you
probably should have done so we can say
well at least I can screw up after this
and how to evaluate the piece second
yeah it's winning for white 95 is
winning the comp instantly is on +2 yeah
I was only thinking okay well this looks
like it's working but I didn't calculate
anything
okay well this says Queen f3 is even
better yeah probably because this is
entirely shot playable due to a maid and
get a move like that you can take here
and this is falling apart problem this
thanks this hangs and so on yeah it's
all all plus two plus three
okay no here g6 where's the defense
bishop c6 is the defense according to
the computer which she didn't play and
this wins for white
but not with the continuation I played
Bishop f6 seems to defend for a bit
this is of course a very attack very
computer slimy but let's say let's check
briefly if after that takes takes I
applied rock III which yeah seems to be
not bad at least but Queen d4 is much
simpler according to the comp yeah hmm
needs to play the smooth and then G form
techniques takes yeah this is +6 so
probably this is directly leading to to
such a big attack that he needs to give
much much much much more material okay
this this this was intending the Queen
Queen second as we saw it was working
interesting enough all right very
interesting thanks for watching